so bad news for joe biden tonight you
may remember that biden was a big backer
of the
violence against women act biden told us
he was doing this to protect women
but now we learn that it's an act of
hostility against women to acknowledge
that women exist it's deep sexism
the word women is itself an offense
against women
assuming women is an actual category we
just learned that
over the weekend democrats voted to ban
gendered language in-house rules
that means no more terms like father or
mother just case you're wondering where
they stand on the family that also means
terms like
women and men are out that's where they
are in biology
and for good measure brother and sister
and first cousin are also banned
on sunday democrats celebrated the move
using the handful of words they have
left us in the english language
i think that the rules should reflect
our values as an institution that is the
most
inclusive as possible that reflects the
gorgeous mosaic
in every possible way of the american
people
it's inclusive and we're going to show
you that by excluding
entire words in fact ancient categories
of the human experience
from our language by excluding we will
include
got that that's the gorgeous mosaic they
described
of course that mosaic does not include
nancy pelosi's own twitter bio
in which she describes herself as quote
a mother grandmother
and dark chocolate connoisseur
dark chocolate connoisseur is the only
term still
allowed hard to imagine a weirder set of
words strung together than those
all in one place but what's interesting
is that almost everybody now
sitting in the house of representatives
is violating these new rules and no one
more flagrantly
that a member of congress and part-time
preacher called emmanuel cleaver he did
it just yesterday
when he led the house in prayer watch
peace
even in this chamber now and evermore
we ask it in the name of the
monotheistic god
brahma and god known by many
names by many different faiths
a man and a woman
amen and a woman so if you thought
amen was an ancient affirmation that had
nothing at all to do with biological sex
stan
corrected how does this empower women
exactly
that's a question that chelsea gabbard
who is a former congresswoman
from hawaii a democrat has been
pondering she introduced a bill last
year to stop biological males
participating in women's sports that
bill is expected to be introduced later
this month
and we said former we didn't mean it
because until january 20th she still
serves
and we're thankful for that
congresswoman thanks for joining us
tonight
so how does it empower women
to ban the acknowledgement that women
exist
it absolutely does the very opposite of
that and it's the height of hypocrisy
for
people who claim to be the champions of
rights
for women to deny the very
biological existence of women and and
this recent uh a rule
change that the house just uh actually
voted and passed on today that you were
talking about
removing references to you know mothers
and fathers brothers and sisters sons
and daughters
from congressional rules and
administration
uh it it's mind-blowing because it shows
just how out of touch with
reality and the struggles of everyday
americans
uh people in congress are but also it it
shows that you know their first act as
as
this new congress could have been to
make sure that
elderly americans are able to get the
covet vaccine now alongside
frontline healthcare workers elderly
americans who have the highest mortality
rates from this virus but instead of
doing something
that could actually help save people's
lives they're choosing instead to
say well you can't say mother or father
in any of this congressional
language it's it's astounding it's
confusing too because
the very people who claim to celebrate
diversity differences
and differences are what make the world
interesting and worth living in in my
opinion
are the same ones trying to impose by
force this creepy corporate sameness
where we're all sort of widgets in a bin
waiting for assembly like do they really
think there aren't differences between
the sexes honestly sincere question
i don't i don't know how to answer or
explain what they think and this is why
congressman mark wayne mullen and i we
introduced my legislation the protect
women's sports act that you briefly
mentioned out of a recognition that
this legislation is actually necessary
when you look at
why title ix was created it was created
out of this recognition that there is a
biological distinction
between men and women and boys and girls
and it recognized that because of that
there needs to be a level playing field
for girls and women to be able to
compete and play
in sports now now the reason why our
bill is necessary to
strengthen and clarify and uphold title
ix is because of the things that you're
talking about because there are people
who
are trying to undermine the very place
by denying
my existence denying the existence of of
biological women it's it's
uh it defies common sense it defies
basic
established science it just doesn't make
any sense
no wonder they called you a russian spy
it was dangerous having you in the
democratic party i'm sorry you're
leaving
congressman kelsey gabbard of hawaii
it's great to see you tonight thank you
thanks tucker